Check out this insane situation that has developed
we have at the same time, on the one hand,
Trumpet's protesting where they chant Fox
News sucks.
And at the same time, if you turn on Fox News
at least that night, you have Fox News continued
a platform continuing to platform the absolute
dumbest arguments about Donald Trump's so-called
stolen election.
Trump is going crazy now, attacking Fox News,
telling people not to watch because on some
Fox News shows, they have acknowledged, you
know, Joe Biden did win after all.
So Trump's furious about that.
Some of his followers are furious about that.
But at the same time, if you watch, you know,
Hannity, Jeanine Pirro, Laura Ingraham, they're
still doing all the same sycophantic Trump
won and Joe Biden stole that stuff.
And I want to look at a few examples with
you.
Here is one of Donald Trump's lawyers arguing
that corrupt voting machine software that
some states used has been used by the CIA
for its own benefit.
I mean, this is like conspiracy.
It reads like a conspiracy fake news article
from from a fake news website, a conspiracy
website, or even just like a satire website.
But this is one of Donald Trump's lawyers
actually saying this stuff on TV expert reports
and some documentation of how corrupt the
software is.
And nobody in our government has paid any
attention to it, which makes me wonder how
much the CIA has used it for its own benefit
and different places and why Dana Haspel is
still there and the CIA is beyond my comprehension.
She should be fired immediately.
This same Trump lawyer that Sidney Powell,
she said that Donald Trump actually won this
election by millions of votes.
How would you hold on?
It looks like he lost it.
No, no, no.
She says Trump won by millions of votes.
Take a look at this, because we're fixing
to overturn the results of the election and
multiple states.
And President Trump won by not just hundreds
of thousands of votes, but by millions of
votes that were shifted by the software that
was designed expressly for that purpose.
Imagine how insane it is that this stuff is
still happening on Fox News.
And yet Trump is still furious with them.
And his supporters were chanting Fox News
sucks in Washington, D.C. over the weekend.
Then there's Rudy Giuliani.
Rudy's evidence that the election was rigged
against Trump.
It's a hunch he has.
He would be surprised if Philadelphia didn't
cheat.
But I mean, the reality is the reality is
the reality is that I would be surprised if
Philadelphia didn't cheat in this election.
They've done it in the last 60 years.
Now, listen, guys, if he'd be surprised, that's
that.
I mean, that's as good as definite fraud.
Right?
And then Saturday night on the Judge Jeanine
Pirro show, the same Trump lawyer, Sydney
Powell, says they should just invalidate the
election, just just delete it as if it never
happened and never being certified.
No state that had anything done to the machine
prior to the sort of prior to.
Right.
Prior to the election without a new certification
is going to have to invalidate its votes.
It's going to have to go to the state legislatures
to be decided ginnane.
And then she goes on to say that there were
millions of votes flipped or erased, not just
in swing states, but even in states that weren't
close.
I am working on the massive aspect of a system
wide election fraud definitely impacting the
swing states and likely going far beyond that.
We're talking about the alteration and changes
and millions of votes, some being dumped that
were for President Trump, some being flipped,
that were for President Trump, computers being
overwritten to ignore signatures, all kinds
of different means of manipulating the Dominion
and Smartmatic software that, of course, we
would not expect Dominion or Smartmatic to
admit.
And then here is Jesse Waters airing his suspicion,
his feeling that Joe Biden didn't really win,
that Biden was installed.
He has a gut feeling, guys.
I thought these were the people who said facts
don't care about your feelings.
But Jesse Waters has a feeling that Joe Biden
didn't really win turbulence, obviously.
But there's a there's a sneaking suspicion,
me and a lot of Americans, that Joe Biden
was installed somehow, someway.
I can't prove this allegation, but it's a
gut feeling.
But that's why you do these kind of investigations.
Do you kind of have that feeling, too?
Yeah, I do, because it's multifaceted.
And the voice at the end there was Victor
Davis Hanson from the Hoover Institution agreeing
with Jesse's gut feeling, just a completely
delusional segment.
And then here's one last one.
This is really funny.
Texas Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick, who
offered a million dollars for proof of voter
fraud, the million dollars still hasn't been
collected.
Shockingly, Dan Patrick went on FOX News and
said, listen, this is a really clear path
for Trump.
If we recount Georgia and Arizona and those
states flip to Trump, then all we need is
the Supreme Court to hand Pennsylvania to
Trump and we win.
Don't you guys see how simple it is?
Recount two states and flip them and then
have the court give a third state to Trump
and boom, he'll be reelected on January 20th.
The official count in Georgia, Arizona, Wisconsin,
Pennsylvania.
And remember, Shannon, there's less than thirty
thousand votes in Georgia and Arizona dividing
Biden and Trump.
And if those two states turn, if they do,
then the Supreme Court could make the decision
on Pennsylvania and then Trump as president.
So I don't know how it's going to turn out,
but we deserve a real count to know what the
real vote was so we can have confidence in
our elections and by who should be the first
person to go out there and say, look, recount.
But the Democrats brought this on themselves,
Shannon, with their suspicious act.
So there are some real questions about the
future of Fox News because it's bipolar.
What's going on here?
On the one hand, they're still doing all of
this insane stuff and claiming that Trump
really won.
But at the same time, because a couple of
reporters have said, listen, it's kind of
over like Trump lost.
That's it.
Trump is mad at them and Trump's followers
are mad at Fox News.
But he still has friends in the nighttime
shows like Hannity and Jeanine Pirro, who
the hell knows what to expect?
And somebody who also seems to have become
completely disconnected from reality in the
last two weeks is Trump's press secretary.
I want to talk about that next